[Musique]
ce soir nos mémoires du zinc sont
consacrés à bruno solo à l'occasion de
la sortie du film pur week-end d'olivier
doran alors franchement là on peut pas
la manquer à un pur week-end olivier
doran alors bruno solo méconnaissable il
ya même des potes à moi qui n'ont pas
reconnu sur la photo
imaginez mais choisir quand pas gênante
un euro au t1 gros chandler un mytho
mais voilà là ce soir on va essayer de
montrer que si quand même une ombre alex
frei des choix de kad merad tout ici
alors on peut faire la distribution
parce que c'est un film choral donc tout
le monde à sa place et c'est important
valérie benguigui et celle en panne
quesnel françois berléand dans
l'hélicoptère avec alexandra mais
recourt offre qui n'est pas sûr sur la
fille bruno solo bonsoir de robot est ce
vous recevoir leur survie ristic
vous avez été découvert un jour dans le
public par le bolloc'h way par le
bolloc'h et thierry ardisson en fait je
faisais de la figuration des émissions
de télé ce jour là j'arrive dans une
mission de tirer des sons qui a pété les
eft en 89 et je suis repéré dans le
public parce que je faisais une contre
ce genre l'un et java ou quoi ça peut
servir le gard et de la peau il m'a dit
belote et manille bâtir un monde sort
c'est la scène avec moi je sais pas s'il
est passé quand j'ai foutu le pied sur
cette estrade
je me suis dit je suis dans la place
jean mus plus je redescends pulsions
descendre je sais pas pourquoi je
sentais que c'était enfin l'occasion
pour moi de montrer ce que j'étais
susceptible de faire mais l'aspiration
du cac et puis voilà c'est ce qui s'est
passé à la fin de l'émission thierry
ardisson en libérant de garde et trois
mois après canal+ nous a appelés pour
présenter le top 50 qui était une
mission emblématique l époque et donc
après les choses se sont enchaînées plus
ou moins bien et je me suis servi de la
télévision comme vitrine pour faire
savoir surtout que j'ai des comédiens
alors donc on va revenir à un pur
week-end pour dire un peu de quoi il
s'agit on le voit on a dit un film
choral c'est une bande de copains qui va
trés traditionnellement faire sa petite
randonnée une sorte d'amitié un pure
routine les gens ça se sent fier
neuvième gain peut forcer il se voit et
ça même plus grands pourquoi ils
s'entendent plus vraiment ils n'ont pas
les mêmes aspirations politiques et
philosophiques
donc ils font leur petite randonnée puis
l'un d'eux fait une connerie et la
randonnée se transforme en cavale hélas
à l'aune de cet événement exceptionnel
il faut qu'ils continuent à être
solidaire et la solidarité
elle est parfois difficile à envisager
dans des moments comme ça c'est là qu'on
voit un petit peu le degré et la force
de son amitié alors on va regarder la
bande annonce du film on l'est on veut
une idée on aura un peu l'ambiance et la
grande bastia détail dérision
[Musique]
et j'ai pensé qu'on pouvait essayer de
faire libérer comptez une association
ged après trois ans pour trafic de
cannabis et passer l'hiver
mais c'est une randonnée c'est un
week-end et disneyland journée on le
ramène vers quoi ce qui se passe il se
passe qu'elle est finie depuis 8h ce
matin sa peine et qui va tous vous avez
une permission de 24 heures et il est
toujours pas rentré d'un plan épervier
est déposé sur le parking de la
gendarmerie caso samedi à 30,20 moi je
vous aime tous tous s'en sont alors pris
ce point fr va se bouger le cul
on va finir cette [ __ ] de randonnée
les parents dol à aller on fait une
cavale c'est plus sportif
tous s'en sortir
à condition qu'on soit tous une et
maintenant que va se poser dans le vide
ou alors on a vu l'ambiance de pur
week-end alors tout à l'heure quand vous
disiez les copains m'ont pas reconnue
sur la fiche c'est pas simplement une
plaisanterie c'est que c'est quand même
un de ses rôles à contre-emploi rapport
à caméra café ou à penser que j'ai pu
faire c'est vrai que je suis un
personnage qui est très introverti
quasiment mutique et tout d'un coup il
va basculer et de venir rencontrer en
personne extrêmement autoritaire donc
moi je vais évidemment quand j'ai lu le
scénario qui m'a plu j'étais en plus
passionné par ce personnage est présente
via ce talent idée de faire un
personnage effectivement qui qui
paraissent d'un sentiment à un autre
avec cette vigueur et cet enthousiasme
alors quand on parler d'amitié de film
choral c'est un peu quand même une
constante dans votre carrière
j'ai par vous proposent souvent des
aides appartiennent à des groupes comme
ça et je pense que j'en tire une
certaine fierté à l'idée qu'on puisse
m'en visage et au sein d'un groupe on va
le voir un petit peu parce que dans les
rubriques qui composent
mémoire disant il ya la première
putching ball qui donne l'occasion à
notre invité de revenir sur un sujet
d'actualité sur lequel il a envie de
réagir
qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi j'ai
choisi j'ai choisi je veux dire un truc
épouvantablement pessimiste j'ai choisi
le prochain le prochain conflit mondial
ce qui se passe en iran en ce moment
fait trembler le monde évidemment bien
de la politique iranienne vont alors non
seulement leur politique ultra
répressive joueurs leur petite victoria
leur politique fondamentalistes
religieux est ça mais surtout leur
programme nucléaire
alors bien entendu qui oserait dire à un
pays comme l'iran d' d'interdire de
développer par exemple l'énergie
nucléaire civile mais on sent bien sans
aucun doute autant n'y avait pas d'armes
cachées en irak
autant il ya sans aucun doute un
programme nucléaire autrement plus plus
belliqueux que celui qui a été défini
par le gouvernement donc on sent que les
américains c'est là ils vont aller péter
la gueule aux iraniens n'ont pas
longtemps et ça me fait très peur parce
que je pense que ça ça donne
véritablement embrasé le monde
ils ont des moyens coercitifs les
américains gigantesque six semaines pour
les gendarmes du monde
enfin les américains le gouvernement
américain les gouvernements républicains
notamment
mais est ce que vous pensez pas que
c'est une affaire aussi intérieur qu
actuellement il ya un échec de la
politique économique en iran et que les
dirigeants iraniens ont besoin d'une
cause
oui pour fédérer leurs peuples
évidemment le pays dans une telle ou
telle détresse que bien entendu ils
l'auraient là ils se mêlent se pose en
bouc émissaire ni on nous interdit
d'accéder au progrès rendez vous compte
bientôt le privé le peuple est galvanisé
enfin semble-t-il des images qu'on peut
voir perdurer leur paraît effectivement
c'est toujours pareil moi j'entendais
iranien kenny multi n'imagine pas la
résistance au liban qui a dansé évitera
de l'autre des intellectuels et même
doté d'une lame d'une certaine classe
ouvrière estudiantine il ya une vraie
volonté de l'aspiration très forte à la
démocratie bon on va râler c'est quand
même moins une note d'espoir et
considérer qu' en iran ils se lèvent des
forces qui peut être qu'on a lancé trois
appels magnifique le peuple à perth
notre séquence ping pong est une
séquence matérialisé par cette petite
balle
obama peut pas faire plus juste c'est
très sportif en sont le dollar et l'or
ce qui est sportif aussi c'est la
critique
ouais c'est un sourire et un sport qui
est violent je vais proposer un combat
clair parce que je vais lire les
arguments de l'intéressé on est dans
premières ou des dents ciné live jedir
un extrait vous concernant le road movie
vous reconnaîtrez qui sent sous les bras
mais que le cache misère d'un scénario
radio thé de partout modèle téléfilm
tout public
donc aucun avec enfilade de galles pas
drôle farandole de quiproquos de masse
broc et pièce montée de son bourreau
elles n'ont pas aimé risiblement 7
continue puisqu'il continue à frapper au
corps solo fait le râleur débrouillards
les rats le bellâtre bidon barbara
schulz la shampouineuse survitaminé ils
sont là tous alors là sagement
tristement mais on s'en fout vrai c'est
que ce
c'était une raison à des missions à
l'appui produits de vidéo clubs en
finisse au plus vite son chéri je sais
pas si c'est le film 600 les dégâts fait
que le film n'a pas marché mais le film
a été un fou en fait je trouve que
effectivement le film avait avait avait
ses qualités dans la première partie et
après il sombrait effectivement dans une
bluette peut-être il le réalisateur
bruno delaye l'a reconnu d'ailleurs à
l'époque maintenant la critique elle est
allée mais là elle a crié beaucoup plus
dur que ce que le film mérite quoi et
non mais j'en ai vu moi pardon j'avais
créé un film négationniste a fait grève
partie avec fabien oteniente qui était
l'histoire d'une journée de grève où les
gens s'arrêtaient travail et donc un
libraire je prenais un ruisseau leur
disait puisque vos corps s'arrête faites
marcher vos têtes
il leur proposait de lire et le film
avait été il y avait une critique nous
tient dans télérama que j'avais trouvé
très bonne très juste parce que il dit
ce film est tellement porteur d'espoir
de bézid et on aurait tellement envie de
l'aimer
hélas ce feu d'artifice promis s'avère
être un pétard mouillé bon je dis qu'une
critique comme ça le fait mal et en même
temps elle me fait elle me fait du bien
me fait avancer
est-ce que vous avez pas comme modèle un
peu la comédie sociale anglaise oui j'ai
ça mais je n'ai pas la prétention de
d'aller vers ça parce qu'il ya quand
même dans dans dans l'humour français
quelque chose d'un peu plus
franchouillard qui fait qu on tirera
toujours verte quand même quelque chose
de plus de plus rentre dedans
oui je crois qu'on n'arrive pas à mettre
cette émotion inhérents à peut-être à la
lame anglaise à la boîte issos alors
vous avez toujours eu envie de parler du
monde du travail monde oui toujours
toujours donc j'ai encore espoir d'avoir
une comédie sociale de rien donné et
puis bien parce que ça continue à jour
d'histoire je renonce pas alors passion
d'auteur pas son auteur c'est l'occasion
pour notre invité et d'évoquer quelqu'un
qui a été important or bruno solo qui
avez vous choisi georges braque georges
perec georges perec parce que je pense
que c'est lui le premier qui m'a ouvert
à ce que pouvait être la littérature
presque ésotérique c'est à dire que
c'était un maître le magicien des mots
rue absolument tel point que dans ce
livre la disparition pour ces cons là j
avais jamais lui c'est un livre de 250
pages en quasiment où il n'y a pas une
seule fois
la lettre qui est un lieu au parc jean
les i je voulais juste un début de
l'exposition trois cardinaux un rabbin
un amiral francs-maçons un trio
d'insignifiant politicards semis au bon
plaisir d'un trust anglo saxons ont fait
savoir à la population par radio puis
par placard qu'on risquait la mort par
inanition ont cru d'abord un faux bruit
il s'agissait dit et on d'intoxication
etc
il n'y a pas une seule fois les lettres
là dedans mais parce que c'est le
rapport entre la forme et le fond c'est
à dire que pour lui ce texte c'est pas
quelque chose nous mangions sais pas ce
que c'est c'est l'image du bonheur est
absolument c'est exactement ça et je
souvent chez terex et ça on croit qu'ils
jouent simplement avec vont ils jouer
avec les palindromes il a écrit une
phrase de trois pages pour concourir
dans les deux sens le fameux pas la rom
c'est laval
c'est exceptionnel parce que c'est pas
juste un exercice de style il ya un vrai
comme vous le disiez il ya un vrai fond
derrière il ya une vraie volonté il ya
une vraie réflexion sur la vie et sur
l'existence je vous les laisse pas ce
que je serais capable de vous les volets
ça serait dommage qu'ils disparaissent
géant maritime journal intime alors le
journal intime c'est l'occasion pour
notre invité de nous enlever dans un
endroit un petit peu privé un petit
panneau blanc je sais ce que je vais
vous montrer le staff je vais vous
montrer ça ça c'est les moulures du café
charbon nous faire face au loin des
ouvriers c'est fait par des ouvriers qui
avaient les staffeurs et c'était le
métier mon papa il a fais avant tout sa
vie et c'est un métier assez patient qui
est complètement quasiment disparu
maintenant parce que les mots leur
maintenance ont fait en polystyrène sont
collés c'est ce plateau la maintenance
et un coup le placo voilà donc je
voulais juste vous montrer ça parce que
mon père mesure dans ma vie c'est mon
et c'est ma fondation c'est ma force
moi j'ai fait une chose avec mon père
que je crois que conseille à tous les
ados de 13 14 ans quand il a senti que
j'allais rentrer j'ai décidé de rentrer
en conflit avec lui parce que c'est
normal l'adolescent de rentrée ont
confié que ses parents mehdi va bien on
veut on se tire on est parti quatre mois
tous les deux en voyage lui est moins à
travers les états unis mexique le
honduras le canada aussi avant le
guatemala juste lui et moi encart
volkswagen avec trois ronds et on a fait
un voyage quasiment initiatique on a
appris à se connaître définitivement
alors mec je conseille à beaucoup de
fils et de filles de faire ça avec leurs
parents bon ben alors justement il est
comment comme papa bruno solo à moi je
suis très très câlin parce que j'ai été
moi très câline et quand j'étais petit
on vous disait beaucoup je t'aime avec
les parents ce le déan tort et je le dis
beaucoup à mes enfants
mais bon c'est légitime et c'est ce que
c'est ce dont tu sais ce que j'espérais
c'est exactement comme ça que je rêvais
des c'est le sujet sur lequel lui
expliquons le grand et le petit champ
aussi faut pas hésiter à commana quand
même c'est mon petit jardin voilà et
alors on ferme la porte du petit jardin
alors je vais me faire un petit cadeau
quitte on n'a pas parlé d'une passion
dévastatrice doit au contraire
enfin le voile a été dévastateur il
n'est pas ça mais ce que bruno solo a
perdu gros au jour ouais j'ai perdu gros
points qu'eux
j'avais 16 ans quand j'avais vingt
balles d'argent de poche et j'ai perdu
mes mille balles là il a fallu que je
trouve même eu du mal parce que le mec
contre que j'avais perdu il avait passé
oui voilà il plaisanté ne faisait pas
que plaisanter quoi bon en tout cas
d'abus du plaisir
alors on parlait de pur week-end avec
bruno solo un fil que vous pouvez allez
voir vous verrez vous pouvez peut-être
tester grâce à ce film l'amitié que vous
avez pour la bande de copains
c'est un bon test en tout cas où nos
solo merci beaucoup merci damien cette
reprise des grades et rigoler c'est de
parler
[Musique]